[Musique]
mais beaucoup de rencontres ce week-end
dans les yvelines pour nous éclairer sur
l'ensemble de ses résultats mais quel
ennemi d'eurobonds soir en soie gris on
commence tout de suite michael ce tour
d'horizon par du rugby oui grégory et
les amoureux du rugby vino attendait ce
match avec impatience la rencontre de
division honneur entre le ska rugby et
vitry longtemps indécise a finalement
tourné à l'avantagé des joueurs du val
de marne
le sky s'incline dans les dernières
minutes 22 à 18 après une belle
prestation
une défaite qui fait redescendre les
joueurs de guillaume payen la deuxième
place du championnat après trois
journées on écoute les réactions au
micro de nicolas d'henri sentiment c'est
que on a bien maîtrisé le match on a
pris les devants et et on a attendu que
ça finisse en fait on a subi un peu la
fin et résultat bat caen attend on
attend la bo défendre la ligne à mon nez
ça finisse fait de voix c'est vrai que
là aujourd'hui mentalement ça fait très
mal parce que c'est notre premier match
à domicile on se disait que ne boudez
klaus allait être incroyable cette
saison quoi et puis en plus avec deux
victoires acteurs pour commencer on
s'était mis dans de bonnes conditions
pour accueillir une équipe comme vitry
malheureusement ce match mais un petit
coup derrière la tête mais je pense que
dès mercredi ce sera oublié et 1 dès la
semaine prochaine il faut rebondir et
oublier ça et repartir sur les bases de
la du début de la saison prochain match
pour les joueurs du sky rugby dimanche
prochain sur le terrain de vincennes
pour le choc de cette poule de division
honneur
entre le deuxième et le troisième du
championnat du monde jouait également
amical ce week end la finale du
championnat de d1 de baseball est hélas
aussi malheureusement une défaite pour
les yvelinois oui oui très mauvaise
opération pour les cougars de montigny
le bretonneux en finale du championnat
de france les minimes ont atteint se
sont inclinés deux fois sur les deux
premiers matchs de leur série
le score à 4-1 dans le premier match et
4 à 3 dans la seconde partie les matches
retour sont programmés le week-end
prochain
montigny-le-bretonneux devra
impérativement remporter ses trois
matches pour espérer devenir champion de
france
mais ça va être très dur degrés on
termine ce tour d'horizon michael part
du football direction trap est ce que
les les nouvelles sont bonnes les
nouvelles sont mitigées en peut dire
dans ce championnat de r3 à trappes a
été freinée par suresnes ce week-end à
les trappistes qui restait sur trois
victoires en trois matches ont concédé
le match nul 3 partout c'est une
histoire de 3,1 grégory mais reste tout
de même sur le fauteuil de leader après
quatre journées trappe comptent un point
d'avancé sur le second à boulogne habits
en cours merci michael on retrouve tous
ces résultats et bien d'autres encore
dans votre émission
c'est à suivre après ce journal le 7-8
sport et